it's some mean time to change I mean
you've been around for a long time my
friend I remember the first time I ever
saw you fight it was a back up backyard
bare-knuckle fight in the Kimbo Slice
days that was the first time I heard
about you and then I saw you fight
Evette words in BO dog I'm the roadog
fight yeah there's a golden age the
golden age is man's a while ago damn
it's crazy like bo dog fight was fun
organization came Velasquez fought their
jail son and fought their Eddy average
that's right yeah fade or fade or had a
fight over there afraid I had a fight
over there brat pick it as well yeah
Mike Brown yeah but what happened with
them they went under because of the the
whole gambling rules on lawn changed
right off from what I heard no and I
heard was a spending budget I this is
what I what I heard um
Calvin there there was the owner boy
right he put up this huge budget and
these are just rumors from what I heard
from the people working you know it was
like 100 million dollars for XYZ amount
of years to get him publicity so people
would see the fights and then go to the
casino that 100 million got blown out
like in 230 years whatever
ah I wouldn't disagree because they used
to pay me really good and give us super
perks they usually give us some super
perks you know take us to exotic
locations to fight be there for two
weeks you plus two that fly out take
care of you they really really took very
good care of you so when I heard that
they blew out 100 million in three years
I was like yeah it could be you know
well they were fighting on the beach
with hot girls of bikinis wandered
around dancing yeah but you were on the
beach like in the Sun I was like what
the who this fucking idea is to fight in
the Sun but let me tell you the training
sessions that went on there were some of
the best that I've seen in the world cuz
they so you would go and you'd bring two
of your cornerman and then somebody
found that and then before you know you
had like four people of your entourage
going with you from whatever team that
was and everybody was doing that and
we'd have a training place in what they
had done was laid out tarps and mats and
it was huge
so we'd have like 100 pros 50 pros from
all over the world just training you
know and you don't know each other and
it's like hey you want a role you know
it gets competitive you know yeah so
some great training sessions that I saw
and that I thought I took a part of you
know
Wow it was fun man a good fucking time
look the the world needs more of those
they need more one FCS we need more
Bella tours we need more you know
competition
whatever the professional fight League
is called now what do they call
themselves now is that what is it's pfl
used to be world series of fighting
that's right yeah we need more need more
of them social PFOS world series used to
be world series downs pfl okay yeah I
think pretty sure most the same
organization oh yeah do you need we need
more you know Oh need more money she
have that Oscar De La Hoya thing you
know that that's probably never gonna
happen again after the the Tito and
Chuck fight it doesn't look like but
someone of that ilk someone like a
Golden Boy Promotions I started getting
involved in MMA and putting together
they could get some guys that aren't
signed but are super high level with a
big name like maybe the contract comes
up and they decide to do something with
a big-name promoter you know it'd be
good for everybody